we're asked to complete the square to
solve 4x squared plus 40x
minus 300 is equal to zero so let me
just rewrite it so 4x squared
plus 40x
minus 300 is equal to zero so just as a
first step here i don't like having this
four out front as a coefficient on the x
squared term i'd prefer if that was a
one so let's just divide both sides of
this equation by four so let's just
divide everything by 4. so this divided
by 4 this divided by 4 that divided by 4
and the 0 divided by 4 just dividing
both sides by 4. so this will simplify
to x squared
plus 10x and i can obviously do that
because if as long as i do i can do any
as long as that whatever i do to the
left-hand side i also do to the
right-hand side that will make the equal
the quality continue to be valid so
that's why i can do that so 40 divided
by 4 is 10x and then 300 divided by 4 is
what that is 75 let me verify that 400 4
goes into 3 4 goes into 30 7 times 7
times 4 is 28 you subtract you get a
remainder of 2. bring down the 0. 4 goes
into 20 5 times 5 times 4 is 20 subtract
0. so it goes 75 times this is minus 75
is equal to 0.
and right when you look at this just the
way it's written you might try to factor
this in some way
but it's pretty clear this is not a
complete square or this is not a perfect
square trinomial because if you look at
this term right here this 10 half of
this 10 is 5 and 5 squared is not
so this is not a perfect square so what
we want to do is turn so somehow turn
whatever we have on the left hand side
into a perfect square and i'm going to
start out by kind of getting this 75 out
of the way you'll sometimes see it where
people leave the 75 on the left hand
side i'm going to put it on the right
hand side just so it kind of clears
things up a little bit so let's add 75
to both sides to get rid of the 75 from
the left hand side of the equation
and so we get
x squared plus 10x and then negative 75
plus 75 those guys cancel out and i'm
going to leave some space here because
we're going to add something here to
complete the square that is equal to 75.
so all i did is add 75 to both sides of
this equation
now in this step this is where this is
really the meat of completing the square
i want to add something to both sides of
this equation i can't add to only one
side of the equation so i want to add
something to both sides of this equation
so that this left hand side becomes a
perfect square and the way we can do
that and we looked at we saw this in the
last video where we constructed a
perfect square trinomial
is that this last term or let's just say
this this what we see on the left hand
side not the last term this expression
on the left hand side it will be a
perfect square if
we have a term a constant term that is
the square of half of the coefficient on
this on the first degree term so the
coefficient here is 10
half of 10 is 5
5 squared is 25 so i'm going to add 25
to the left hand side and of course in
order to maintain the equality anything
i do the left hand side i also have to
do to the right hand side
and now we see that this is a perfect
square we say hey what what two numbers
if i add them i get 10 when i multiply
them i get 25 well that's 5 and 5. so
when we factor this what we see on the
left-hand side simplifies to this is x
plus 5 squared x plus 5 times x plus 5.
and you can
look at the videos on factoring if that
you find that confusing
or you could look at the last video on
on constructing perfect square
trinomials i encourage you to square
this and see that you get exactly this
and this will be equal to 75 plus 25
which is equal to 100 and so now we're
saying that something squared is equal
to 100. so really this something right
over here if i say something square is
equal to 100 that means that that
something is one of the square roots of
a hundred and we know that a hundred has
two square roots it has positive ten and
it has negative ten so we could say that
x plus five the something that we were
squaring that must be one of the square
roots of a hundred so that must be equal
to the plus or minus square root of a
hundred or plus or minus
plus or minus ten or we could separate
it out we could say that x plus five
is equal to ten or
x plus five is equal to
negative 10. on this side right here i
can just subtract 5 from both sides of
this equation and i would get i'll just
write it out subtracting 5 from both
sides i get x is equal to 5 and over
here i could subtract 5 from both sides
again
i subtracted 5 in both cases subtract 5
again and i can get x is equal to
negative 15. so those are my two
solutions
two solutions that i got to solve this
equation we can verify that they
actually work and i'll do that in blue
so let's let's try with let's try with
five i'll just do one of them i can i'll
leave the other one for you i'll leave
the other one for you to verify that it
works so 4
4 times x squared so 4 times 25
plus 40 times 5 plus 40 times 5
minus 300 needs to be equal to zero four
times 25 is a hundred forty times five
is two hundred we're going to subtract
that three hundred hundred plus two
hundred minus three hundred that
definitely equals zero so x equals five
worked and i think you'll find that x
equals negative 15 will also work when
you substitute it into this right over
here